[Music]
what's up party people
welcome to a very special episode of
honest trailer commentaries uh this is
the show where we
uh talk and watch about uh what am i
saying i'm just so excited dan's here
look it's dan
hi everybody it's not a rerun it's
really me
look uh if this is your first episode
it's gonna be a weird one uh but you'll
catch on
dan how are you doing i'm doing good how
are you guys it's great to see you
yeah we're great we're still in our
boxes as you can see yeah none of us
have moved
um and uh you did
yes you moved a physically different box
yes
physically emotionally and and digitally
because the people can now find you on
youtube.com backslash
dan mural movies that's correct the
greatest uh
i i dare say the greatest uh a movie
channel on the internet
i'm not even gonna uh i'm not even gonna
add any reservations it's the greatest
channel on the internet oh yeah i would
say that that's thank you thank you very
much i'd say go watch mr sunday movies
but i'd love if you came and watched me
too that'd be great
so uh we are uh we're here for uh for a
serious reason though we're here to talk
about uh the honest trailer for lost
which you
have been working on for a really long
time right like you've been in the lab
for a few months
it's been cooking up you know back when
we were all working together when people
would ask stuff like why don't you do
movies like lost or tv shows we'd always
say like well we don't have enough time
well
it turns out during the pandemic when
there's no movies coming out
um i had enough time to watch lost
and work on the trailer for it so yeah
this has been cooking for
many months many many months yeah we
finally finished doctor who and then
immediately
lost next up let's go get right back on
there um
now i uh i probably i didn't have too
much time but i probably
could have had enough time to fill in
the blanks in my cultural knowledge
which does not include
lost i've seen two episodes of lost one
was the finale
and the other was where a british
musician
dies on a boat um
yeah his name accurately yes the band's
name is drive shaft
put some respect on his name they seemed
like lovely episodes i didn't get what
all the fuss was about but i do one day
no you wouldn't it's shocking coming in
at the finale
it didn't pay off for you i watched the
guy die on a boat and i thought
not for me um i like my deaths on land
but and joe i believe you're in somewhat
of the same boat like you're not a lost
uh
i have also died on a boat spencer um uh
yeah
you've seen two more episodes of lost
than i had oh wow
oh but i also missed dan a lot that's
the thing
yeah we both missed in a lot um this was
uh
uh there was input from people like lon
uh and danielle who have seen the show
um but we just wanted to say hi to dan
hi
all right bye see you guys have fun
watching the trailer
dan and what do you guys think about
this the tv series
lost over i was i was an obsession for
me i was one of those
lost maniacs who would watch it every
week and then
go online and look at the breakdowns and
the screenshots and go on the forums and
read
uh doc jensen's article on entertainment
weekly
uh i mean i was i was obsessed i was
deep
deep deep into the show so i was a
real-time viewer which is going to come
into play
uh in the trailer because there's one
particular criticism that i make that i
see push back on
that i think is unique to real-time
viewers um
so i was obsessed with the show very
obsessed with the show and i've kind of
done a bell curve on the finale like i
started out like
it was amazing and then i hit like some
pretty low lows on it and now i'm kind
of like back up towards the middle
so it's been a very interesting journey
i've probably seen the show all the way
through including this time
four or five times well there you go so
what could what could noobs like us add
to that insight
what's your what's your last take uh i
got into lost while it was on tv i think
towards the end of season one i was like
all right
i'll get into this thing everybody loves
it and then yeah i got i got really
hooked it was the show that
got me into after shows and
getting in communicating in real time
with a lot of people on the internet
about what you were watching like
i think probably the very first podcast
i ever listened to that was specifically
about a tv show
would have been about lost and like dan
i would like week to week
when there's mysteries and there's new
stuff and like what the hell is that
four-toed statue like i would be on the
forums and try to figure it out along
with everybody else
um i've only seen it twice all the way
through
uh you know once when it was sort of
like on tv and then i went back a few
years later and like watched the whole
thing
start to fish again i'm not i think the
first four seasons are like why
yes delightful i i i think that's where
it gets creaky to me and i i do have
some issues with like the last c
i think the problem is more the last
season though than the finale
episode like i don't know if we'll get
into this more but i really like the
finale
it's really more like i i feel like the
last season kind of jerks you around
rather than coming up with a satisfying
way to like draw all the threads
together
yeah i mean it seems like um it's kind
of a
just a recurring thing it's more often
than not beloved tv shows end poorly
um and i think that there's an economic
reason for that is that they keep
getting renewed if they're popular until
they're not popular and they're just
like all right well
we'll end it now they're not writing
towards something continuously
um yeah but you could tell with lost
that they weren't like by season four
which is still really good i think you
could tell like oh they are just
every year they're coming back to the
table fresh and like how do we
okay here's where we're at where do we
go and i think even today
like loss was so influential in its
moment like it was
that first generation of peak tv where
they were sort of
doing these season-long multi-season
arcs and really getting into it on that
level
but yeah today even today i think you
would have more of like a
flight plan i'd like to see what lost
was
if it were made five years later because
that's very much what they were doing
was they
got they got it it was like every other
tv show they got picked up for 22
episodes a year and then maybe they get
picked up for another 22 and they
actually i think
in toward the end of season three going
into season four they went to abc and
they were just like
okay listen we're spinning our wheels
here we've got to start building towards
something and they were i think they
were one of the first shows to to not do
to say we're not doing 22.
on network tv cable and obviously on
network they're like we're not doing 22
we're doing 13 in this season and we're
doing 11. and then it all got upended by
the writer
strike and they had to change everything
um but yeah
it did set a lot of precedent in that
way where they just kind of said
like we don't have we can't do 22 a year
with this story we're gonna do fewer
and now like a lot of shows do that
well i would have liked to see lost if
it uh i would like to see las vega came
out uh
20 30 years earlier and they had to do
like 46 episode seasons and
it's gilligan oh look there's bob hope
on the island next door yeah
he's gonna literally gilligan
it's really fascinating to me how
quickly that has because that's the
mandalorian
sort of like it's it's there there are
ongoing plots but it is it's very like
episodic to week like what tv used to be
and it's amazing that people are so
thrown by that
we've it only took like one generation
for us to like forget that that's what
all yeah but i mean the mandalorian has
like 10 million
in episode production budgets um which i
also would like to see for gilligan's
island
it's still basically like have gun will
travel it's like what's that
poachers bothering your ranch i'll be
right there like it's just that every
week and like
and that's fine it's like la la like
there are plot lines but then
basically i gotta sue this guy and he's
sort of famous
you're like all right that's where we're
at this week yeah well it's part that in
part you know people being like
character work
where's my stuff i'm a star wars fan
i want stuff yeah uh sometimes you don't
want all the answers
but you do uh so with that let's start
our honest trailer for
lost
[Music]
from creator jj abrams comes an iconic
turn-of-the-century tv show
that became a pop culture sensation
featuring
a first season that had viewers
wondering what's in a box
and a time traveling final season that
left most fans disappointed and confused
felicity
[Music]
oh and also lost well
admission to make i was not a watcher
full city but
i i remember when it was on hearing that
like the last season they did like a
time travel thing and i was like oh that
could be interesting like an interesting
parallel and then i was reading more
into it and i found out that like in the
first season that just like lost they
had this box that was like this big plot
point and
it never was like literally a mystery
box that never got explained it's like
okay that's an interesting
so yeah that does not come from a place
of information on felicity but
i tried to do my research there it
seemed like a very such a weird genre
thing to dump on to like
i don't know like a cw-ish narrative
show
like if yeah that turned into an
inception plot like in season three
the final season of felicity i i
remember is like basically made against
his will
um like he wanted off he was done with
it so he's like all right
i'm going to turn it into a completely
different show somewhat out of spite
which i always support
well i think they if i recall correctly
they were just like all right jj you're
done and they were like wrap the show
and they're like actually
no uh we want like 13 more and he's just
like
all right i guess i'll just restart
start over
yeah yeah it's amazing with the mystery
boxes like
when he's developing these shows or
pitching them
does an executive never ask him what's
in the box like is he able to razzle
dazzle them and be like
like throw some glitter in their face
and run away like how does he keep
getting away with it apparently
yeah he's a snake oil salesman spencer
jj abram sits down in a room and he's
just like you know what you need you
need this box it'll razzle dazzle
yeah he had that what was it like a ted
talk or he talked about
this and like you know it's basically
like you don't ever open the box that's
the
that's the like philosophy of it that on
some level it has to stay a mystery or
it's going to be
lame so i guess it shouldn't be
literally he's right yeah can we at
least go to metaphorical mystery boxes
and not literal
containers you get into the chekhov's
gun problem
if you show people a box the but you've
got to open
the physical box itself yes yes all
right let's keep going yeah
wow jj did that twice how does that even
happen
prepare for a zeitgeist defining drama
that started with one simple question
where are we then ballooned into so many
more
what is the black rock what do the
numbers mean what is the monster
who are you people that bridges say my
name what is a nigerian priest doing in
an island in the south pacific
what happens to pregnant women on this
island that even the creators eventually
got tired of answering them
what do you mean get back here what do i
mean
eventually folding it um
my my role in this honest trailer was uh
was small and eventually insignificant
but i think it's an interesting story
uh we wrote a section of uh
of all these questions that that people
had about
um about the series and uh i
was able to get in touch with a certain
uh person of influence on the show to
see if they would like to come on and
answer them
or give give funnily flippant answers to
uh some of the mysteries of lost the
questions that they've been asked over
and over again
they declined they did they were not
interested in coming on and
and giving anybody answers funny or
serious or or not
um yeah so uh yeah i think um
it was fun to write that email though
with like if you could ask this person
your questions about lost and i was like
lickity split i'm on it chief
i got a couple i got some thoughts well
and i also love i don't blame them but
you know as the
you know as the the creative uh
the beginning creative force by the
episode it was particularly pleasant to
read the feedback that was like
well you know in a very kind way saying
like we don't find any of this
particularly original or interesting or
something that hasn't been said or asked
before about the show i'm like
i'll take it oh you know what i've been
lobbing some criticisms too i'll take it
yeah i will i do have to say though of
all those runs the question runs
for me as a fan the the the hurley bird
as it was called amongst the fandom and
you saw hurley's did that bird just say
my name
is the epitome of why are you putting
this in the show
is they put a bird in the show that
flies over and makes a sound that sounds
like hurley
which is why he says did that bird just
sound my name
never mentioned or explained ever again
uh and that's where i think when people
get frustrated with the questions it's
not that they had
questions it's that they had meaningless
questions that were inserted
somewhat randomly yeah you did get the
feeling that there was a thing where
it was like there was not even it wasn't
like okay we have to fully explain that
right now but there wasn't even a like
are we ever gonna be able to like it was
like setting impossible stuff for
themselves
that there wouldn't be any way for them
to really explain
almost like they were it was like a
challenge that they were
not up to and like i think that's the
part that irks people like a little like
threads that don't get tied up i think
is one thing
but introducing like crazy stuff
that you have no plan for yeah um
that's why i didn't jump in because kind
of at the height of lost mania i was
like
okay do i need to go to best buy and buy
seasons one through three of lost on dvd
for you know fifty 50 a pop and there
was a there was an interview with the
with the writers where they were
basically like we don't know we don't
know where it's going
we're just kind of throwing stuff at a
wall and i was like
oh that that seems
like a cheaty way to go about your show
whose premise is
what does it all mean if you don't yeah
they said that and then i remember
toward the finale as we were getting
down to like single-digit episodes left
people started asking like well what
like
there's like a list of like here are the
things that haven't yet been explained
and
a lot of the response from the from the
producing and writing team is just like
well the show's not really about answers
it's more about emotional satisfaction
and we're like
wait a minute hang on you made a show
about questions for five and a half
seasons and now
now you're telling us it's not about the
answers like what about what am i doing
with my life
some stuff is crazy there's a there's a
bid in season two joe and spencer where
they're
they're like a bunch of our central
characters are on a boat trying to get
away from the island and another boat
shows up and just starts shooting at
them
and we never find out to this day
who was in that other boat what was
their motivation to shoot at them
i don't think you can as a responsible
writer write that
like you can't write that scene and not
in your own head be like well who are
these people shooting yeah i think you
could put that into really any
island-based piece of fiction and and it
works just you gotta have a
castaway just a boat start shooting
pirates
are they people from like not having a
thought
tremendously irresponsible on some level
imagine castaway and tom hanks is on the
cliff with wilson
and then like someone takes a shot at
him like a bullet just zooms back
like a red dot on his head
he stands in the middle of the road with
the fedex boxes and the movie ends and
you're like wait a minute who was the
sniper on the island
like i feel like i don't think it's
unreasonable that i should
get the answer to that question well
it's also kind of a blessing though that
this didn't come out
uh 10 years later because you know it
was on abc right
yes it was and on investor day they'd be
announcing uh
uh boats the boat series uh
the series the series
to this day i am i like i always expect
this like that's one of those things
that i feel like any day we're gonna
they're gonna be like
some sort of animated thing or a prequel
thing or like i don't think lost is dead
forever they're going to reboot this
show
we're going to go back we're going to go
back i know that much
we have to go back all right keep going
eventually folding in on itself like a
question singularity
as the writers booby-trap this tropical
hell with literal mystery boxes
and one mystery whose answer is still an
actual question mark
i want some freaking answers us two dude
us two return to the island
a mysterious monster inhabited death
trap that no one will shut up about
welcome to the island everything i did i
did for the island the island killed him
the island isn't done with you yet the
island isn't done with you yet
the island's not done with the [ __ ] yeah
well i'm done with this island and meet
these plane crash survivors who probably
shouldn't have flown the same airline
that got hijacked in executive decision
this is an oceanic 3-4-3 heavy
requesting emergency
landing their son
oceanic is apparently it's it's appears
in other movies as well prior to lost
oceanic was like the five five
five of tv airlines where
you know if something bad was going to
happen to a plane obviously like
delta or american airlines is not going
to put their name on the plane so
oceanic was kind of for a lot of people
like the go-to
airline and then this movie then this
show came out and you then it's just
it's the lost airline so they ruined it
for the rest of us yeah yeah if anyone
else uses oceanic now it's like oh
so it's a cinematic universe
right didn't i think that happened once
right there was another show where it's
like is this plane going to the lost
island like now
just it was just a generic name that
they threw on planes
right now and they never so they never
named the island it's like that was one
of the mysteries that it's the island
the island is the island the only actual
aside from a couple of notes on trims
and timing my only
written contribution to this trailer
none of you actually got
because my joke pitch for the island run
was to end it with
the rock saying dramatically welcome to
the mysterious
island and then i was like i don't think
any of my friends have seen
journey 2. journey too i've seen
starring barack
it's one of the starring names i think
right it was not sent to you
oh fair enough never self-censored joe
come on oh yeah
we've all seen the brendan fraser slash
dwayne the rock johnson franchise
journey
to the center of whatever it just makes
me want to go to
um fast casual burger franchise uh
islands
and get a burger with a piece of
pineapple on it wasn't there also
a real reality show or something called
it wasn't there
an island oh there was a netflix show
called i land that you hated
oh yes yeah
[Laughter]
one thing that i didn't write i thought
about putting in was that
there were there were a succession of
shows on abc following lost
that were the next loss one of them was
flash forward
yeah oh yeah yeah flash forward was like
this is
the next lost and then it lasted like
one season and then
v and there was the the good one that
was about all the people who disappeared
right the
um on hbo uh oh yeah the uh not the 4400
the
the missing is that the no but yeah yeah
that one too right there yeah so many
obviously
they're still doing this last season abc
had emergence was that what it was
called with uh
yeah with allison tolman it was the same
it was like mysterious plane crash then
this child appears that doesn't
seem to have come from anywhere like was
it a sci-fi anomaly like they're still
trying to like it also seems like
there's a millionaire
because now we've started remaking other
countries versions of lost
like france had a show it was like these
people vanished a year they haven't aged
what happened
and then we remade it yeah there's like
a zillion of these now
the leftovers that was sort of the
leftovers on hbo yeah
but the french one is all just about uh
it gets really into french
age of consent loss that's what it is
well the leftovers is also
like leftovers was like a lost like guy
did did that i think lindelof's come out
you know smelling like roses with uh
with
leftovers and then uh and watchmen after
this yeah
but i think we still we still ding him
at the end let's let's see
let's keep going
the millionaire and locks knives
the music star the confessor and scary
man
here on gilligan's eye sorry
where where will we get there's jack
shepherd that spent
an embarrassing amount of time to come
up with a joke based on a 50 year old
television yeah and
it's tricky when you um when you write
uh stuff for john to sing because it's a
it's a real coin flip whether he uh
whether he knows the
the song or not but this one man he he
dove right into it
well then the question's like where's
the transition does he sing the whole
thing does he start in the middle like
yeah
for a gilligan's island joke that that's
so glad it stayed in
trying to come up with a way to work the
harlem globetrotters in
but were they on gilligan's island
the yeah globetrotters show up on
gilligan's island at one point
what a weird time in television and in
basketball history
they were the go-to crossover of course
yes scooby-doo gilligan's island harlow
yeah everybody they would show up on
your tv show yeah they're it's in the
name they're the globetrotters that's
what they do they trot the globe and
they meet people
that's true and occasionally play
basketball where is the show
the washington generals yeah where is
the show about the washington general
snapping about it should be it's like a
cobra kai
type well you know washington generals
that'd be great my understanding was
that they're like the understudies
they're
they're globetrotters in training so
it's like you want to be in the big
leagues you want to win a game like you
got to get dunked on for two years
every time i didn't even think of that
that makes a lot of sense yeah every
time i think about the washington
generals i just think about the simpsons
when chris is like krusty you bet all
your money's like ah they would do
the generals were hitting the ball on
his finger he was using a ladder for
crying out loud
uh i was once uh dunked over with like
seven other children at a
at a um harlem globetrotters game never
got over it
you and sweet lou out there yep
all right keep going jack shepherd the
torture doctor who ultimately turns out
to be a likeable hero
sawyer the tortured con man who
ultimately turns out to be a likeable
hero
saeed the tortured former torturer who
ultimately turns out to be a likable
hero
kate the tortured murderer who
ultimately turns out to be a likable
hero
charlie the tortured drug addict who
hang on these are all the same people
even the objectively evil mass murderer
gets a redemption arc
i forgive you thank you john
that does help oh well i guess we still
have nikki and paulo
razzle dazzle
yes that's from the show do you know the
saga of nicki and paulo
uh on lost no okay so this was during
their growing pains of the
third season i believe the third or
fourth season i think it's three
they were running out of they had these
main characters and they were running
out of things to do so they literally
have these two characters nikki and
paulo who one day on the beach
kind of run up from the jungle and
they're like what's go literally that
what's going on guys and they're like
nikki paolo go do this and you're like
what the hell and then and then it's
like we've been back there the whole
time
and they have like an episode where it
shows like where they were in the
background
and it's like a crime story where
they're like they're smuggling diamonds
what and they like they're stashing
diamonds on the island
one and a half loss this is like uh like
season two of friday night lights where
mtv was like have somebody kill someone
it has to be a murderer they were they
were like one of them was like an
actor though so there was like a show
within a show which is what that clip is
from
nikki was an actress and she was on the
show co-starring billy dee williams
yes um that was kind of like fox force
five the right fiction tv show
and so and paulo was like her lover
slash they
murdered a guy and then they had
diamonds and everyone hated them
so much that they they they
after like 10 episodes they were
literally buried alive
after being paralyzed from a spider bite
real life poochie it's like actually
poochy
that they added these cool new
characters and everybody was like i hate
this
and then they were like oh well we'll
murder them and then you don't have to
worry about them anymore
and they get buried alive and it
literally is like
nikki apollo are dead they're never
coming back folks like yeah it was that
explicit it was amazing
and it was very shortly after that that
the
news came out that they had gone to abc
and said like we need to set an end date
uh so and in many ways
they could have pulled it off in like
season one because you had your
characters you got to know and then
there were a lot of like
extras on the beach in the background we
were like presumably other people were
on this
more people yeah and like they could
maybe introduce us to them later
and there were a few like mr arms or
whatever like peripheral people you meet
briefly
right but by the time they tried to pull
this with nikki apollo it's like no no
you're way
you're not there one ain't passed
yourself by there's no way there's
people on this island that we just
haven't seen
you gotta crash another plane into if
you're short on characters
just crash another plane gilligan's
island
it where it's like the harlem
globetrotters team playing crash lands
on the island and now they're there
in season two that's what they did they
crashed the other half of the plane on
the island and they were like here's
what was going on on the other side of
the island so they'd already done it
once yeah yeah and the second
running out of because they were
fighting right the back half and the
front half
well no they were like trying to find
each other and then there was a third
group called the others that they were
fighting
there was a group that was already on
the island that they didn't know about
yet but we
got it and like all that is fine it's
just like you you've got there's
reason there's a limit to how much we
can just how incredible though could
nikki of paw
and paulo have been if throughout the
first three seasons of the show you were
actually seeing this weird [ __ ]
happening in the background
all the time you're always like what are
those two doing that's weird
that bird just said razzle dazzle were
they counting a bag of diamonds in the
background what was that
and then that's the sort of thing that
like today you could do
because you know you were gonna get more
episodes you could plant stuff like that
yeah for yourself like pay off later
laundry are you suggesting that people
should watch netflix's gary hodgy
which does that well which oh my god
there's one i'm not gonna say what it is
there's one moment like that that is a
like good thing they dribbled in in
episode one that they pay off
all right stay on target let's keep
watching all right there you have it
trying to figure out what it is in real
time as it veers wildly from a
character-driven drama about plane crash
survivors
if we can't live together we're gonna
die alone
to a gritty showdown between two warring
factions
this is our island to a whole season set
mostly in cages
also season three i remember that i saw
i saw i did see some cage stuff
yesterday they're referring to you
as the oceanic six to a sci-fi show
about time travel i'm from the future
to an epic final battle between two
immortal brothers who fight over pulling
the
plug out of the island which will
unleash evil somehow while our main
characters all meet in the afterlife so
they can go to heaven
really it's complicated but every time
you're ready to walk away and swear
you'll never watch again
the show will deliver a moment so epic i
love you i think that's the one i see
we have to get back
you'll forget they devoted entire
episodes to jack's tattoos
charlie's visions zombie saeed and
hurley trying to start a van
[Music]
so pause i mean that's just a function
of happening back on having too many
episodes oh go ahead dan
hurley's starting to start a van i've
seen a lot of people say like hurley
trying to start events one of the best
episodes of the series and i will say
if you're watching the show all the way
through it is a very good episode
however i if i may defend my stance here
that when you're watching the show in
real time hurley finds this van in the
jungle and
he it's like a metaphor for him fixing
up cars with his dad and it's very
it's a great character episode when
you're binge watching the show i would
like to point out it was in the middle
of the third season an aimless third
season
with characters trapped in cages it was
the episode immediately following the
worst episode of the show which was the
how
jack got his tattoos episode which is
completely pointless
uh and and so in the context i have a
bias against that episode because when i
was watching it week to week
after the whole debacle with jack and
his tattoos the week before
now it's a whole episode with hurley and
a van and i'm like what the hell is
going on with this show like this is
ridiculous so
i will i if you're watching if you're
binge watching the show the hurley van
is great but i think that there are
probably some viewers that watched it in
real time that may have been a little
frustrated by that yeah
is it like that it's like the fly
episode of breaking bad where i was
gonna say
terrence and philip not without my anus
like you're at this point where you're
really waiting for some reveals and to
move this thing forward
and it's like yes take it on its own
this is fun and enjoyable i like it but
not now
like you gotta you gotta gotta give us
something that i forgot about
retroactively you understand why that
van is important but in real time you
don't it's just an abandoned van in the
jungle
that's an episode on re-watch that gains
a lot but that i agree the first time i
saw it i was like
when are we gonna get to the fireworks
fashion exactly yeah
uh tangentially joe i finally saw
orgasmo for the first time this weekend
and i
couldn't stop thinking about you
watching it with your dad
it's a good bonding moment that must
have been oh it wasn't
just me you got a trick it's called
orgasmo how did you not know
oh well briefly joe the story okay so uh
i rented uh orgasmo and was like this is
hilarious
and then because i was like this is a
wacky comedy had no problem with leaving
it in the vcr
and then my dad later was like joseph uh
uh i need to talk to you and like gave
me this whole
weird uncomfortable talk about porn and
and i was in big trouble because i left
this porno in the vcr and i was like
damn this isn't a porno and he was like
it's called orgasmo
i was like no it's a hilarious comedy
i'll prove it
and it's really like a reverse you're
gonna smoke every cigarette in this
carton
i just made my dad you made your dad
watch all of orgasmic prove it's not a
porn
yep uh i think uh uh
uh by the time someone farted in
someone's face or i think by the time
chodoboy put his helmet on my dad
laughed and i won congratulations
thank you very much well done i wanted
you in life
i understand now now i fully understand
okay back to lost
start a van
but no matter which era of lost you're
watching get ready for six seasons of
stories that all
unfold basically the same way where we
start with an extreme close-up of
someone's eye
then someone comes running out of the
jungle whoa
whoa you're good right there right
before it starts to rain
then someone beats the crap out of ben
you know what i love
don't you do what you need
[Music]
someone tells lock what he can't do
don't tell me what i can't do
don't tell me what i can't do don't tell
me what i can't do
k croys
[Music]
if i may eventually lily
she got a very thankless role because
again when you watch the show all
together
kate's character is it's literally like
they're just like what she can't do
uh in reaction to this thing like i
don't know cry
like she cries it's like she cry she lit
her reaction to everything is like
and kate cries into like every script
and eventually lily
pulls it off like i mean she should
she's
a lot has asked of her on an acting
level and there's a lot of crying on the
show
i'll grant you but kate seems to have
been given most of the crying
it's it's weird like i i kind of felt
for her as well by the time you get to
the end of the show it's like
the kate jack sawyer story it's
so it's just so repetitive like they
don't move it forward it's basically
she likes both of these dudes they both
like her they can't quite figure out how
it should work
for six seasons and like you would think
that there would be more of a rise and
fall
that never really happened so they just
don't have that much to play it's like
they're kind of always
playing out the same two or three
scenarios yeah yeah they should have
just gone full throttle
just i mean you're on the you're on the
island yeah it's like sandals jamaica
yeah this is the sawyer and then they
try
and then none of them were too they're
all dating other people like that's what
you got to do to keep this thing moving
i mean they literally go back to the
1970s at one point
the the the time when the threapel would
not even
have blinked an eye at a throttle away
yet uh no
yeah if i was on an island where there
was a smoke monster birds were saying
people's names maybe
all normal it's all off
it's like close everything it's all
everything's off
yes to be naked and unafraid in
a couple weeks yeah i do feel like if
this show was today instead of when it
came out
there would be like a little bit more
like it's still very much like
and then these people couple off and
then these people couple off and then
these two pair up
you would get i think a little bit more
of like uh
do they get like oh look some some old
navy shipments like washed up on the
shore or
are we to believe that they just
withstood years and years of uh the
elements in the same outfit they were
traveling
asking if the hot pants from the
simpsons happen
they do find clothes they find clothes
well it's at some point they like rab
they scavenge all the bags and so
they're like oh we got a bunch of
clothes from these bags
that came like they find the luggage
other people brought but also
as we've said it turns out there are
other people on the island there is like
a town there and so like they eventually
come up with ways to explain
there's a town yeah well technically the
town is on the adjacent island
oh but yes there is civilization oh yeah
you mean island town it's uh
it's style of dover literally that's
kind of one of the reveals it's like
next door there's an island town where'd
you get that starbucks
oh yeah after like several seasons where
you're just on a tropical island
where they just walk into a town that
does happen that is actually one of my
favorite
uh reveals is like the the others which
are like the people that they're
battling they set up as like these like
dirty grungy like island inhabitants and
they're literally just people with like
fake beards and old grungy clothes and
they find like a locker with all their
stuff in it
no way yeah they're cast aways but no
they've just been living in a town
yeah nice all right keep going hey it's
gonna it's gonna be all right
it's good and there's a team meeting
where jack gives a speech
every man for himself is not gonna work
everything's gonna be okay
it's gonna be okay everything's gonna be
all right just have to be patient
okay and leads a group into the jungle
where something happens that causes them
to
run run run run keep damn it
not the run until a mind-blowing episode
ending reveal
punctuated by a michael jacquino music
sting that sounds like every sound ever
made
all played at once
[Music]
for me michael jacquino's origin story
oh yeah
that's like that like that's where he he
made his his big splash was doing the
music for lost but i
i don't like it still to me like defines
his
sound it is very much his sound yeah
like whenever i hear
him doing something else it's like it's
like 80 percent losty still
it's great music to be fair like i know
we're having a little fun with it there
but i mean
it was it had a symphonic sound to it uh
yeah i mean it because it's worth saying
like that's what to me like going back
even now stands out it's like the the
technical aspects of loss like in terms
of
it really is like you get why so much tv
became so much more cinematic
after this like lost set a new standard
for like
basically being a movie on television
like it looks amazing
the sound is amazing the cinematography
is fantastic like
they did however they were still asked
to execute visual effects on a tv budget
and some of it looks really bad yeah
really
today looking back on that era in
digital effects
sure yeah you're watching it on like an
sd you know
uh 20 inch tv um if you're watching
1987's but
yeah it was still like live
i'm behind the times it was one of those
wide screens but it had four feet of
television behind it those really yeah
exactly nice exactly man all right keep
going
so get lost and revisit one of the shows
that ushered in an era of peak tv
that was doing audience favorite
anti-heroes before breaking bad
genre driven viral marketing before
heroes and
unpredictable character deaths long
before game of thrones red wedding its
way into your heart
it's like the dear sister snl sketch
that gave us the geniuses behind 2009
star trek
hbo's watchmen and netflix's daredevil
who are also the same geniuses who
brought us 2019's the rise of skywalker
ridley scott's prometheus and netflix's
the defenders
how can the same people do things so
good and so bad
unless their plan was to intentionally
destroy all the established franchises
from the inside
paving the way for groundbreaking
original television like
lost they failed
the lost the lost writers room they were
like
the the go-to's for so long that's why
you saw like damon lindelof and
uh like uh carlton cuse and
all the writers drew goddard and they
made some great stuff but like
for a while it was kind of like the it
was kind of like the simpsons thing like
you put a bunch of executives in a room
and they're like who should develop this
and then like close the door they're
like
lost guys lost guys yeah okay get us
someone like the lost guys go brainstorm
so the lost guys great
that's great great yeah like the kids in
the hall of premiere television
yeah pretty much like they everything
every script every new
franchise every hot idea had somebody
from lost attached to it so it was bound
they were bound to be mixed results
yeah i mean but that's that's that's
hollywood baby you just need to do
one good thing just one and then you're
david goyer
um or pic
what's his face yeah yeah you're just
the go-to guy for anything
even tangentially related to that genre
but i do think that they've
they've acquitted themselves more or
less well you know jj
i don't know not so much but i think the
other ones have uh uh
have done some good work post-lost well
that's the frustrating thing like i
think it would almost be better if like
everything they did was sort of down the
middle like oh yeah that's pretty good
for me it's like the contrast is what's
been so hard for me to grapple with
is like jj abrams has done some of my
favorite things in the world
and then with little to no middle ground
he's done some of my least favorite
things in the world
and that and like and that goes with
like lindelof it's the same thing it's
like it's just so it's not so much like
everyone has ups and downs for me it's
the disparity
between the two it's just like sometimes
they're like oh how does that happen
obviously because i wrote that part of
the trail this is just me venting really
just about like my life and life let's
give you that platform
um all right let's let's keep going
through star
boss starring
matthew definitely a fox professor x oh
that's a that's a callback to what world
war started out with
it started out with vivica definitely
could definitely not
fox and then there was
not actually a fox not actually yeah not
actually a fox and then
it's like that it's an old school honest
trailer joke yeah i don't know anyways
keep going
professor x middle earth who's the
fictional band that's a hit with all the
fans
drive shaft you're damn right the snack
from iraq
gambit the campfire diaries the love
boat
dude perfect dude dude dude
uh dude the kid's gone ben
solo billy d williams no new pope yet
oh concussions
you're gonna die charlie you're gonna
have to die john richard said i was
going to die
mr whitmore told me richard albert said
that you were going to die the miracle
of birth
this was weird it's the number of
[Music]
demons that were very similar
penny
there's a lot of stuff on the show about
pregnancy
on the island and giving birth on the
island
that that is another example of one of
those things that they never really
wrapped their their old find out what
happens to babes on the island
well we did we found out that pregnant
women on the island died
and then there was some sort of a
because there's no modern medicine
no it's it's more like some weird
inexplicable thing that you see some
energy you see there's a plug on the
island guys
sure um there's a plug on the island
that that
that energy comes out of and it's a
crazy energy
but when you pull the plug then evil
can leave i think this is the plot of
mist
there were there were it's like rick and
morty there were two brothers
two brothers and one of them but both of
them were immortal
but they had a mom but but then one of
them died but not really because he
because he turned into smoke and
then there were there were two brothers
and then one of them is a dead becomes
lock
lock is a brother lock is a brother and
now
and now there's one brother but then now
there's two it's it's
just it just came down to two brothers
and the problem is there's 18
quadrants and there's only nine jan
michael vincents
they might be riffing on that native
american folk tale that everyone has two
brothers inside them
and which brother wins two polar bears
on their island
whichever brother you feed becomes the
big brother
uh okay keep going
friendly log hello charlie hello james
hello desmond hello syed hello benjamin
hello jacob hello echo hello hugo
hello jack hello rose hello richard
hello kate
i just killed the chicken nicknames
how long was it freckles how to score
the house call dr quinn you sure know
how to butter a man up steakhou
sulu over here is packing a suitcase
full of salted fish you want me hot lips
welcome back dr wizard i think it's mr
wizard shut up
pillsbury cool hand deep dish chachi
sally slingshot
barbar kenny rogers what's your problem
jumbotron
shut up red nick man oh writers right
he's need a therapist i i felt a little
bad for jorge garcia because
yes the character of sawyer is very mean
to hurley oftentimes and makes these
jokes up in character as a mean way to
insult his weight but
the writer's room still has to basically
sit and make fat jokes about hurley all
the time i feel a little bad like
all right we need a dozen fat jokes come
on what do you got what are you doing
like
if you i mean if you're if you're if
you're flipping through the script you
know if you're just like okay and you
just like every script there's a fat
joke about you
like at some point i think the exclusive
like but he's a bad guy
it's gonna run a little thin like yeah
but come on yeah i feel like
this guy gives everybody hilarious
nicknames is one of those things when
you're writing a pilot you're like
brilliant this is going to give me a fun
runner and then by the time you get to
season three you're like what was i
doing with the nickname thing my god
how do you keep that over so many
seasons it's like you've written
yourself into a crazy dumb corner like
now you gotta write hundreds of stupid
nicknames for everybody
that sounds fun it's like starring it's
like their own little starring
everything yeah like in avengers you
could parcel
that like iron man only has to do it
once every like movie or two but in a tv
show it's like ah he's around what's he
gonna call him this week yeah
he'd be calling people nicknames
constantly crazy
why doesn't he make fun of his horrible
personality instead it's all
probably lots you could make fun let's
be honest
okay keep going problem john voltron
shut up
red nick man a writer's room in obvious
need of therapy
my mother was crazy
well i guess we don't always turn out
like our mother's one
how come you never talk about your dad
john nothing worth talking about
what your dad never taught you to use a
hammer
no my dad taught me how to drink yep dad
everyone's got a dad is he cool no
dude that guy's a total douche that
douche is my dad
and michael talking they're not taking
my son away
they took my son they took my son they
took my son
took my son because of you
i'ma get back my son i have to get my
son back
i'm going after my son he's my son my
son
where's my son i want my son it's my son
lost no really i'm totally lost can you
explain it again
very quickly maybe
talking about short-sightedness i that
was the problem with walt
which is that in the first season
michael has this son named walt
and it's set up that like he's special
and he's got special powers and he's
very important
but the writers didn't think about the
fact that their show takes place over
the course of a month
like literally the first two seasons are
only a month
and they cast like a 12 year old kid who
grew up
and you can't be like walt whoa you
walked behind a tree and you got six
months older and so then they had to
keep walt off screen
but then you had to drop the whole story
line about how he's special and then the
entire second season is literally that
run of michael just being like
i gotta find my son i gotta get my kid
back i gotta get my kid back
and then and then they had to like write
walt off the show completely because
they're like well we can't explain that
you've never
heard now and they never really put a
pin in like
what exactly there's a while where
they're they're teasing like what's the
reason they're here
like walt's the key to the whole mystery
of the island and that's why
that's why the plane had to be brought
there like they needed walt there to
make something happen
and then it just dropped it's just like
ah forget wealth it didn't matter anyway
yeah you can't just you can wreak what
about all this other stuff
don draper had different kids every uh
every season yeah right bobby draper's
different every season that's true
yeah well yeah there's a lot of that
through the whole show loss where it's
like that magician's trick of like oh
what am i doing with my other hand it's
like we still know that you've got the
coin in that hand
you haven't moved your hand you you
still have both hands
sorry teller but uh the pens over there
with the with the rabbit
all right keep going maybe jen would
have survived if he just learned to stay
off boats
just do it
yeah well bravo well done damn thank you
thank you very well done uh i i it makes
me want to watch lost i don't feel like
uh uh
i know a lot has been technically
spoiled but i i know it won't
stick when i watch and i will be shocked
and delighted uh that's a crazy volume
it's still a good show on volume it
i i i it doesn't quite congeal as much
on my
this latest rewatch as i'd hoped it does
still feel slightly herky-jerky and
episodic but
on not episodic meaning week to week i
mean the show literally is just like
well
now we're this now we're this and now
we're this uh but
it on volume i think it's still a pretty
good show
connects it's amazing and there are a
lot of individual episodes that are
all timers like fantastic it's really
just as a whole it's like
that's spotty based uh purely on just
watching the honest trailer i have my
theory on what the show's about can i
bounce it off youtube
yeah what do you got everything in lost
is
all the elements and lost the characters
all the weird stuff going on
the boat that's randomly shooting people
the plug um
these are all the creative things that
jj abrams
wanted to be working on instead of doing
the last season of felicity
and that's why that's why the ark is
similar
that's why some of it doesn't wrap up
because some of it's just like ideas he
wrote in a notebook and never got to
revisit
because he had to do that extra season
of felicity yeah well i will tell you
joe
i wouldn't have mentioned this except
that you nailed it the last
scene is actually it zooms out and it's
a snow globe held by felicity
it turns out that that's exactly what's
been happening yes
and then that zooms out and it's it's
just a story that felicity is telling
her hairstylist as she's getting a perk
yeah yeah
don't you think that'd be a cool idea
for a tv show and then that zooms out
and their salon is in a kyber crystal
in a lightsaber and ray lights the
yellow lightsaber and says i'm ray
skywalker
yep yeah it's ray it's ray shepard now
now she's ray shepard
i've been ray lost if there's something
that happened and lost
and it's a twist you didn't like uh a
wizard did it just remember that
yesterday
oh good times um thank you all so much
for watching uh
after you're done uh subscribing to uh
dan morrow movies uh come on back here
and subscribe to uh phantom
entertainment hit that like hit that
bell so you never miss a video
um and check out some of the other stuff
we're doing it's a very crowded week um
we got a lot of stuff uh
coming up we have a non-spoiler review
of wonder woman 84 with roth and eric
you can watch now
and uh a video we made where we can
prove that die hard is a christmas movie
uh with science um there is now you can
shut that discussion down before it even
starts
uh uh thanks to our help so uh go
go click on those after you finish
watching this video um and there's still
more of this video left can you believe
it
we've got outtakes oh do we have
outtakes we do
let's check let's check it out starring
commander shepard what did the party of
five fingers say to the face
jack kryan the mighty oak quinn lock and
key
kill me kate the fugitive the old
republican guard
dude rogue danny oceanic the wrath of
khan
only lovers left alive not so gentle ben
smoking kills gunshot wounds
i'm carrying a nuclear divorce
yeah that's right jack i've been running
through the jungle toward the sound of
gunfire because i don't care about
michael
jack i've got it covered john he brought
sawyer back half dead with a bullet hole
in his shoulder john jack i know there's
a shut up
fantasy island flakes on a plane
journey to the mysterious island
the lonely island
[ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] look i know this is
network tv and all but there's still no
way a hard-drinking x-con grifter like
sawyer would be so uncreative with his
profanities
yeah yeah it's a good point he's so
creative with his nicknames i think he
did yeah
very colorful swearing if this was hbo
for sure it's dirty
all right we also have some uh questions
and comments from viewers like
yourselves
um i'm just gonna pick some of these at
random uh
uh but um let's do this broad one from
kimberly a is lost still a binge
recommendation or are there specific
episodes that you can enjoy out of
context
oh i it's to be tough to enjoy out of
i think you're gonna have to binge it uh
my i would say
if by the end of season four you're not
hooked like i gotta see how this thing
ends you you could you could stop you
could stop yeah
if you get to not penny's boat uh then
you're not there then you're not gonna
be there
all right and uh ombre to california
right so we all agreed desmond hume was
the best character right
he was a great character yeah we did not
much to say in the trailer which usually
means it's a really solid character when
there's not much uh yeah
i was a big fan of desmond i like them
all he features into
one of the standout episodes i would say
the constant
uh but i i mean i don't know if he's my
favorite character visibility so much as
that's one of my favorite episodes
yeah uh and then finally from uh
johannes
stromer uh is there a tv show you've
watched all the way through and then
wished you hadn't
um
[Music]
dexter dexter sure i wish i'd get like
dexter
season four is a perfect series finale
and then it goes on for four more
seasons and i watched them all and i
wish i had not
i remember feeling somewhat relieved
that i would not have to continue
watching 24
when it ended because i was just i was
felt obligated to keep watching it i
don't feel that obligation anymore i've
jumped off of a lot of shows but yeah
when 24 was over i was just kind of like
ugh okay good we're done yeah i mean
game of thrones is an obvious one that
that leaps to mind for me um wow
what a bummer and that show has just
completely disappeared from public
consciousness and my own consciousness
just
haven't even thought about it since
since it ended after being obsessed with
it so
it's so crazy like i i agree like i was
like game of thrones i used to think
about it like two hours a day
minimum like like not like 10 years ago
like a year and a half ago and now it's
like i never think about that show
yeah they got me back when they that you
know they're teasing the stuff about the
like
the real deep targaryen prequel show and
i'm like
okay like i don't know it's starting to
like gears are turning my
vicerouses from my viserions from my
vicenias and whatevers but
uh man that that just like cratered
everyone's interest in it
if that show had stuck the landing the
casting for the spin-off would have been
like
our biggest entertainment news of the
month like the internet
that doctor who was gonna be a targaryen
we would i think that's the clearest way
to see it because it's all sort of
anecdotal like oh people don't talk
about that as much but yeah like there
will be big news about
house of the dragon that would have
driven conversation for three days
that's just like a blip and you're like
oh but oh you know this one
olivia cook's going to be in it we
haven't even covered it it hasn't even
made a script for us
the solid snake casting made script yeah
and that's like that's crazy because he
used to drive he was the number one tv
show in terms of driving views
yeah it's really crazy what a fall from
grace um
but what a rise from the ashes for you
dan merle i don't know
i framed it that way now i go back to
the grave
ashes to ashes uh once they leave
california they're dead to us
that runs at the ending of the joe
schmoe show ashes to ash's dust to dust
uh whatever their name was you're dead
to us and then they'd smash the plate
with their put their face on it that's
right
but but that's not the case with dan dan
we hope you'll make many happy returns
and thank you so much for uh for
i wouldn't say giving us a week off
because we're all cramming to uh for the
holidays but for
taking lost onto your ample broad
shoulders my my pleasure i would i'd be
happy to to
to to uh take eight months watch another
tv show and make another trailer anytime
watch what you say because uh we've
tried to lob some weird ones your way so
uh yeah
after doctor who i could do anything
smash i feel sensible uh
yeah bring it on friends all right sweet
sesame street
finish
and lost this calendar year yes wow
what a year what a year it has been oh
baby
binging any more shows
spencer can i uh uh can i inside
baseball the uh the what we were gonna
do at the end of the year because at
first i was like let's just make dan do
it
what were we gonna do uh the the horse
one
the horse one the the
oh my little pony yeah yeah yeah well
you know
we've we've done our uh our we've got
our hooves deep into my little pony but
we're not done yet so that's a
that's a teaser for for calendar year
2021 but it's not right
for a while dan dan next time you say
joe's a good friend know that
uh behind your back i was going let's
just make damn let's just make dan
finish
my little pony we've watched half of the
900 episodes
50 episode seasons it's fine i'm not a
good friend
no i mean you're a real applejack joe
i have them all memorized anyway so i'd
be happy to i watch it every night
two night two hours a night and have for
20 years i haven't told anybody that
until just now
classic uh applejack is the worst yeah
classic fluttershy
you're total fluttershy of the four of
us um
but uh uh to tease you for next week
um an extra bonus tease uh
it's something that we might not have
time to do but i think we'll we'll find
some
uh we'll find some time anyways uh we'll
figure it out but it'll take some
puzzling
uh we'll we'll get it together um until
then
same uh uh same bat channel same bad
place
uh we'll see you next time on australia
commentaries thanks for joining us bye
[Music]
dan
you